an open letter to the YouTube science
community my name is Eddie Wu and I'm a
high school teacher from Sydney
Australia my subject areas are maths and
technology actually I'm sitting in a
maths classroom right now and I'm one of
the many people who have benefited from
the time and effort and insights that
you've poured into all of your videos
and so I'm basically recording this just
to say thank you and to encourage you
guys to keep on doing awesome stuff and
making great learning material but I
also wanted to tell you a little bit
about why I'm so grateful for you
specifically the science youtubers like
Derek from veritasium and Brady from
sixty symbols and all his other channels
and Destin from smarter every day and
Henry from minutephysics or microphone
Vsauce or Hank from scishow all of you
guys firstly I see the impact you guys
have on the students that I teach you
know when I was a teenager and I was
their age I basically use the internet
exclusively to procrastinate and waste
time but they don't just do that on the
internet because of you guys they're
learning and they love it and I think
that's priceless secondly even though I
love it and I'm fascinated by it I never
studied any science in high school or
university in the part of Australia that
I live in you get a choice in the last
two years of high school to study
physics chemistry or biology and because
plant Lee I didn't like the style of
learning that was associated with those
subjects in high school and also because
I really enjoyed the humanities as well
I didn't have the time or the units to
study those and so you guys are giving
me access to all this great learning
which I love then and lastly I record
and upload my own stuff as a teacher and
just what the lessons that I give to my
own students it's not really on the same
level as what you guys produce but
seeing the material that you put out it
makes me really excited and it pushes me
to explain and illustrate and teach
better so thanks and keep it up
we love what you're doing and we really
look forward to the next thing that
you're gonna help us learn